welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the witch
of being greenlit for a second season
many fans are excited to see what's
coming down the line
so toss a coin to you which air sit back
and strap yourself in because throughout
this video we'll be discussing
everything we know so far about the
upcoming show we'll also be giving our
thoughts on what the series could be
about and what the showrunner has said
in regards to it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't seen the
first season yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of the witches season 2
okay so the second season was greenlight
on the 13th of November 2019 and though
it doesn't have a set release date just
yet we can use Netflix is really
scheduled to roughly judge when it will
be coming out typically shows on Netflix
tend to have a release annually however
the production costs of The Witcher are
very very high the show not only has to
line up with Henry Cavill filming
schedule but also scout locations and
have all of its special effects
completed Variety recently reported that
filming will begin in 2020 with a
planned release of 2021 which yeah I
hope it's not that long away filming for
the first season began on October 31st
2018 and it wrapped in May but with the
production being pushed for a second
season way before its release in
December it is likely that things are
underway in order to meet this deadline
as for the cast showrunner Lauren s
history confirmed that Henry Cavill and
yet you Lara and Freya Allen will all
reprise their roles season 1 ended with
Siri asking who yennefer was and season
2 looks to focus on the characters
finally crossing paths with one another
and all being on screen at the same time
this was handed out by his rich who in
an interview with GamesRadar stated the
following what's great about season 2 I
can tell you is that in what we've
written the story becomes much more
focused this is stronger Drive in the
story because all of the relationships
that we've been setting up in season 1
actually start to come into fruition in
season 2 there has been no mention of
tryst this for but I'll discuss how I
think she may come into the show
later in the video the season is also
gonna follow a more straightforward
narrative with there being no real time
jumps and everything happening in
chronological order as for the plot it
is set to pour from multiple Witcher
books and to draw heavily from much of
the existing source material though the
first season was based heavily on the
last wish collection the second season
will be an amalgamation of many works so
it is possible that we could see things
that feature in the Wild Hunt in the
next season they were paid lip-service -
in the first season so there is
potential that they will pop up here
personally I think that the season will
focus heavily on series training at the
hands of Geralt and once she's at a
certain level they'll join yennefer in
halting the nilfgaard invasion which is
currently ravaging the landscape in the
books
Geralt did take Sarita kale Mahan in
order to hide her from the nilfgaard
forces and train her to become a witch
air during this time ciri was haunted by
nightmares of cahier aka the man with
the winged helmet and she also drank
white seagull which sent her into a
trance in which he prophesized gerelds
death trying better to understand his
power the which is called fortress
who came and helped to decipher exactly
what was going on now whether it happens
like this we are unsure of as the show
does differ slightly from the books in
several key ways and originally in them
Geralt was gonna call on yennefer but do
you doubt they split up he instead opted
for Tris though Tris was a part of
season 1 in order to shorten everything
I think that they may end up switching
things up a bit and have yennefer meet
Surya at this point I think this will be
a heavy focus in season two with
yennefer perhaps being the one that's
called and thus she will lead the
training allowing the three to connect
properly we don't know this with
definite but with just eight episodes
this may be the quickest and easiest way
to adapt it for the screen this was kind
of hinted at by his rich who said when
you get to season 2 all of those things
start to come to play which is that the
characters start meeting each other
sometimes getting along sometimes not
all those things we set up
geralt and yennefer Geralt in ciri
yennefer and Surrey all of the different
kingdoms that he just barely hear about
in season 1 start rising to the surface
in season 2 so it does look like
yennefer and ciri will indeed me at some
point in the next season so it does make
sense to set this
during a training especially with Siri
asking who she was in the finale
obviously this is all up in the air but
I do feel that a lot of this was set up
with the close of the prior season so it
would make sense to traverse this
direction with the plot especially as
its heavily laced with series backstory
either way I'm massively excited for the
season and I can't wait to see what
happens in the future now obviously I
would love to hear your thoughts on the
witches season two and what you want to
see in it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up make sure you check out our
entire breakdown of the first season
which would be linked at the end we go
over the timeline and its ending so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below
we drop videos on there early so if you
want to see stuff before anyone else and
that's the best place to be it's free to
join and we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
also giving away a free copy of Joker
which is one of our favorite movies of
the air and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
witch or in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
you